Hey, if you're going through a difficult time
- trials and tribulations - they will come.
You need to understand that and know that.
God is not always just going to take you out
of it because He wants to teach you endurance.
So that you will be able to overcome
the challenges that are in front of you.
Not just to sort out the
situation you're in right now.
I'm going to read a quote for you from my book
called Bold Pursuit that I want you to listen to.
Through trials we learn that we can never
find true joy and peace from temporary things.
Joy and peace come only from God
even in the middle of a storm.
Jesus said: "I said these things
to you that your joy may be full."
Your joy doesn't come from things -
from people - from this temporary world.
It cannot.
If it does, there's a problem
with your relationship with God.
In Him is everything you need.
I love you guys and I'll
see you in the next video.
Bye.